Silicon Valley Bank was brought down by
a one-two punch big losses in the value
of its Investments combined with lots of
uninsured depositors when those
customers learned about the losses they
withdrew their money that triggered a
bank run hundreds of U.S banks are
facing similar risks that's according to
new research by Stanford GSB Finance
Professor Ahmed saru saru and his
colleagues looked at nearly 5 000 Banks
to see if they were exposed to the risks
that caused Silicon Valley Bank to fail
they found that due to Rising interest
rates the average bank has seen the
market value of its assets drop about
nine percent in one year overall the
banking system has racked up 2.2
trillion dollars in unrealized losses
many banks with big losses also have
above average levels of deposits that
are not insured by the federal
government that makes them especially
prone to bank runs which means the banks
could be left without enough money to
cover all of their deposits so what
happens if more Bank customers get
nervous ceru and his colleagues
calculate that if half of all uninsured
customers withdrew their money at once
the FDIC would have to spend 10 billion
dollars protecting deposits at nearly
190 Banks the federal government's
decision to cover all deposits at
Silicon Valley Bank may have prevented
more Bank runs for now but saru says
that that alone won't solve the deeper
issues threatening the stability of the
U.S banking system